devil that's the isite believe they
believe the HEB I don't know you it's
all confus that's I'm saying become
Muslim cuz you know Hebrew Israelite I
tell you what
bro any look my sh yeah what would tell
you look listen yeah Hebrew Israelites
is a movement it was a reaction of
racism in the in America Hebrew
Israelites kets Nation Islam
all of these movements or groups they
became they start as a reaction of
racism by the white people in America so
you don't believe it at all that blacks
can be no no no I do I do I believe
Moses are black and Moses was an
Israelite no what's the problem then no
there's no problem with that the problem
is when you say only black people F
you're behind look at it again
I
don't we like you though we like you I
be hon we like you we like
you
no but listen listen look listen well
listen to me you know in the Quran it
teaches us not about skin color it's not
about your skin color it's about your
heart and your actions Allah
said the most beloved or the most
righteous person with Allah those the
most vulnerable person with Allah is the
righteous person and righteousness is
not by your skin color you can be so
Adam and you're evil person you
understand and you can be so white and
you are evil you can be so black and you
are evil it's not about your skin color
it's about your belief and your actions
that's why God is the most wise why you
always beefing people bro I'm not
beefing
I'm
in
right I think
you're misplacing our passion we don't
want be I'm chickening not be anyway
listen listen care yeah why we say to
you look in the Quran he says is
Israelites is a message for you if you
believe
isit isit remember my favor upon
you believe is in the Quan I believe
Allah Allah favored them over other
nations before anymore before because
why they were following prophet and
Messengers but when they become very
stab even the Bible it they become stab
that's worship
that's are following other nations you
know so Allah saids fulfill my promise
and I will fulfill yours what is Allah's
promise upon the Israelites if a prophet
Muhammad come to you you follow him
Allah will bless you you understand do
you know that Prophet Muhammad is in the
Old Testament huh did you know that
Prophet never read that man I never read
that in the Old Testament never never
seen
that that's why I've never seen name in
Genesis no it's not about name about
description
this watch even Jesus name is in the old
test I'm a little bit of a schar little
some of a scholar as well
you you read okay listen to this okay
the servant comes to glorify the Lord
behold my servant who uh who I uph
my elect one in whom I saw the light I
my spirit upon Him He will bring forth
Justice to the Gentiles non Jews
Gentiles who are they the Gentiles the
Gentiles who are they the non-
Israelites yeah yes so this person is
not the Ser is not coming for you I mean
it's not coming for you originally it's
coming for the Gentiles yeah but watch
this yeah said Here let the witness or
the wiess and it C is wildness the
wildness
yeah and the cities lift up their voice
the village that K inhabits let the
inhabit of s sing who's
kada that's
deep is that the
of I tell you Genesis 2513 he tell you
here we go Genesis 253 yeah and these
were the names of the sons of is you me
yeah the sons of is by their names are
called their generation the first born
of is is
then so this service is coming from I
would have have a book for you I no
problem but this servant the servant is
coming from kada to the Gant house and
we know Prophet Muhammad's go by to
because is son of is so historically
speak even if you put Mar of sah is in
Saudi even he says about new law he
would sing new
song before he he good enough wait wait
stop stop look look tell me who he's
speaking about tell me who he's speaking
about
okay show me Jesus name show me Jesus
name in the Old Testament show me Jesus
name in the Old Testament not in there
that's it but see he's been prophesied
about yeah you see so the neb is
conditioned then all right cool then
tell me why this man is coming to gtil
and he's from kada is this the Bible no
this is a AR
[Music]
book J who
else honest yes that's right that's
right the VES
inhab
inhabits one there only one person on
one person and why speak about is son
is I'll do my research on that and I'll
respect
that all right cool but however look
what we say to you look
here uh when you look the Quran the qur
there's many verses speaking about
Israelites okay that Prophet Moses is
been mentioned in the Quran more
Thanh about Israel right no no no listen
carefully listen carefully but you you
have to understand isra they have been
cursed yes so and Israelite been
blessed when you say curs what do you
mean that's in the Bible God curs isites
but God said that it's not me Jeremiah
let me show you Jer what he said 8 what
jeriah said I'm going to show you
something surprise you that Jeremiah
said to you people you have change
scripture jeremi what about what about
the people that built the pyramids what
about the people that buil wait wait
before that read Jeremiah 88 how can you
say we are wise and the law of the Lord
is with us look the four spent Of The
Scribe certainly Works falsehood you
know what that mean do that mean it
means that the scribes chish the law in
the uh the Hebrew it actually says Torah
yeah Torah T it actually says Torah so
so so so the Jeremiah speaking to the
Israelite and he goes on men many evil
things is like this that's worshiping
the idols so listen I told you you have
we have a message for you as israelit as
Israelites there's no success for you
except by
mham that's Allah said the Quran fulfill
my promise I fulfill yours you know
Allah yes Allah did favor the Israelites
over other nations you know but this
this called General one that doesn't
mean every Israelite is better than
other person Other Nation but now Allah
thean you are the best people or the
best Nation out
people Israelites
Israelites the people that was in Egypt
I know
that the people that was in Egypt slaves
in you believe that
was how many times is Jesus mentioned in
the Quran the many times how many times
is Muhammad mentioned in the Quran uh
Jesus more more yeah does muhamad say
wait wait before that before that
Prophet M shows us Prophet the the Quran
is not made by Prophet Muhammad because
if he was made by Prophet Muhammad he
will mention his name more than other
people's names that's the second one
Prophet
mam doesn't say it says in the Quran he
say no it doesn't say s i I will
challenge you to show me
the wait wait wait wait okay does it say
that Jesus s in thean wait wait wait
before that it doesn't say that mamad
doesn't say that it does show me in theh
mam go I can't see in that find it and I
show you in the no do you believe you're
Edomite I'm a Christian no but are you
Edomite you know
edite you don't know Edomite in the
Bible Edomite the white they say the
white man's Ed man that's what they say
you believe you're a devil okay what did
Jesus say says you're a
[Laughter]
devil think it's a good thing think it's
a good thing I think white people are
mainly racist you think racism is a good
thing but you are racist so my fa says
there is no Jew there is no Gentile
there is no Greek okay we all made
that's what my God Old Testament says
that that's what Jesus
said in the old the old Jesus is the new
what about
Jesus before you leave mamad I'm going
to get get he just made a clear Muhammad
s have to
go before you go say you're running away
run running away look look look before
before he goes before he goes in the
Bible Jesus was a racist according to
your belief because Jesus said to the
canite woman you compare that to a dog
because she was
Israelite yes in the Bible when the
woman came to him seeking help from him
I'm being careful with what I say on
camera now yeah I Lear I learned my
lesson
bro we're not inciting hat against you
by the
way Jesus looked down upon a woman
because she was not Israelite she was a
canite and you compare to a dog in your
book you about racism that's a I know I
know
in was red and hairy that's what I
[Music]
know look the new Jesus new C Covenant
yeah comes to fulfill the law of Moses
before start preaching please where
Prophet mammad Prophet I can't actually
get
my there's there's none there there's
none there
give his phone give him your
phone all this religious stuff it just
just brings that SAR just brings
that attention that you know Ian it's
good to have
attention obligation of the Lord of
creation you know I mean that's what I'm
saying bro but look look why you have to
become a Muslim why be a Muslim because
Moses is a Muslim Mo Moses himself to
God that's what Muslim mean Abraham
careful with you guys man don't worry
about the camera me please look Satan
that tells me not to be a Muslim my boy
yeah that's Satan that's Satan no doubt
about that Satan Satan Satan yeah I show
you a woman that become mus Jamaican
woman where country you from originally
from here origin like your parents where
is it from
Carib I show you the grandma Jamaican
Grandma yesterday become Muslim with us
alhamdulillah she saved you know my wife
Caribbean Muslim
alhamdulillah don't have heart attack
don't have heart
attack as a black woman yeah black power
Hey
listen I don't know I need I need to do
a bit more research I mean I need to
look even in the firstage of thean
saying like you're not Muslim
you're no doubt about that sense only
way Muslim you have to know Muslim the
first page of the Quran it says say that
it get the Quran he doesn't say that
show me where it say if you're not a
Muslim claims
and when he made a claim in the chapter
the first chapter yeah show me when the
first chapter if youlim you go to hell
the first chapter that's not the first
chapter by the way
on not the first Inu I still
looking stop reading the anti- Islamic
website what your name sir what's your
name it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
listen stop reading anti-islamic websit
name
ISS
come I'll come back on my way but look
you should look up if you're isite or
whatever
at the prophet Isaiah he fors he fors he
tells the coming of Jesus as the Messiah
say Muhammad and he fulfills have you
read Isaiah 42 Gary Gary have you read
Isaiah
Gary okay just look at this
conversation and even look list to this
he's quoting you your
Bible you said you said that one thing
it's not there it's not no you know you
know look way you have to understand let
me ask Abraham what was
he Abraham what was he a black man about
skin color belief system brother what
belief system yeah but in terms of
belief and Bel what belief
system he submit himself to God that's
what Muslim mean was isites
yeah he's Israelite he was not Israelite
Israelite in order Israelite mean you
came from the lineage of Jacob how
Abraham is Israelites when Abraham came
before
Jacob wait didn't Abraham get his name
changed to Israel no that's Jacob that's
so who's Abraham then Abraham was the
father of that man the Father
the the father of that man so Abraham
was not Israelite because Abraham had
ish and and Isaac Isaac had Jacob Jacob
name changed to isra isra had 12 tribes
okay so therefore that's why in the Quan
Allah
said King Meo know truth is coming truth
let me let me TR the first we're not
killing you we're enlightening you
enlightening you is I Ain read all of
this stuff in
time maybe a few months ago you the man
better time I could have told you but
listen to this but listen to look look
how all the future argum
look how Allah refused the argument of
the Jewish and the Christians claiming
that Abraham was Israelite or a
Christian what was Abraham
there look what Allah said look what
Allah said the Quran Allah said ibraim
was not a Jew or Christian he was a
Muslim submit himself to God alone and
he free himself from the shik and his
people polytheism and paganism
and uh who is it Muslim hanif hanif was
upon uprightness you know so Abraham is
the father of the prophets and The
Messengers yes free from pois from pism
so Abraham was a Muslim Jesus was a
Muslim he submit himself to God alone
that's what you become Muslim mean to
submit yourself to God according to
God's teaching you believe the Bible has
been
corrupted has it been corrupted
yeah no bro ain't been corrupted you
sure I sure you he been
corrupted corrupted okay let let me ask
you does God regret does he regret yeah
yeah can you can regret you know what
regret means we don't know something no
that doesn't that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean regret tell me what regret
means yeah tell me regret means what
what you say that I don't know something
me when you regret something when you do
something then you didn't expect the
outcome of it then so what reget is like
all right I pick this I pick this up
yeah yeah but then I regret picking it
up I'm upset that I picked it up why why
why you upset you understand why you
made regretting bro why CU you made a
mistake like I picked this up yeah but
then it it hurt me yeah so I regret so
he didn't know he was going to hurt you
that's why I knew it was going to hurt
me so I still pick it up no that's wait
hold on the difference between God knows
everything is
it God knew he was going to feel
regretful that's what I'm telling no no
no go he knew he was going to feel
regretful no according to the Bible no
he knew look look look listen he knew he
was going to feel the when you bring out
that argument cuz I've seen you bring
that argument in listen to me look l God
knows everything bro so he knew he was
going to
regret so God said in the Bible the Old
Testament he said God regret for
choosing S as a king because he turned
his back on me so he regret because he
because Paul turned his back on God so
did God know that Paul or
Saul so why grateful truth in him then
that's his plan
bro God's plan is God's plan is God's
plan no one knows what God's plan made
mistak regret when you make
mistake you see I regret I trusted so
and so to look after my shop because he
stole certain items from it regret is
basically a deficiency showing that you
didn't know the outcome of something yes
that's why I regret it it's like a form
of Sorrow for an action you've done in
which you clearly have come to know now
that it was the wrong thing to do this
is not it's the wrong
decision that's why we regret God God
wants to regret something he can do
thato that might be his plan that might
his plan say you know what I'm going to
give them a chance yeah and I know
they're going to I know they're
going to mess up I know they're going to
mess up but you know what you you said a
minute ago God all know it you see what
I'm saying how can be when when he says
that he regrets yeah he might not even
know that it's going to hurt him that
much yeah but you just made another
Deion he
might he might not have known that
listen going to hurt me yeah but when
when actually happened yeah when it
actually happened it burnt him it burnt
him up so he said you know what that I
regret that you
understand might not known that it's
going to hurt him that
much understand heet knew he was going
to feel regret but he didn't know it was
going to hurt that much that's why he
regretted yeah but you know what you
just said there bro he didn't know it
was going to hurt that much he didn't
know you might not know that was going
to but that's not the God we should be
serving them manici in his knowledge
then he said one minute ago in his
knowledge defici in his knowledge
brother God is a complicated thing bro
is very
complicated know everything but not know
everything understand that's a paradox
how he knows everything but not
everything go viral again don't go vir
again you're going to go viral for that
one
aot you
don't I believe is compx that's what I'm
saying look step by step I believe God
is conf things about God we cannot
understand no doubt about it but what we
speaking about that which we know about
God for a fact for example we know God
has a perfect knowledge if he has a
perfect knowledge he has no deficiency
in his knowledge if God has deficiency
in his knowledge therefore he cannot be
where is God where is God right now me
to let him land let him land focus focus
focus yeah if God has has a perfect
knowledge which we agree with then
someone says to me I worship God who
doesn't not know everything he cannot be
the same God who has a perfect knowledge
that's a paradox that doesn't make any
sense that's why you're struggling
that's I'm saying that's why in the
Quran that's why we to the quranic
teaching Islamic teaching it goes in
line with our sound intellect our
natural information because God created
you what does your God tell me that that
he knows everything bro tell me he knows
everything knows
everything so he a lied he said he he he
made a grip so so wait hold on you make
God like a human you know brother
brother I'm saying you're saying that
these are two different gods no what I'm
saying you're saying that the god of the
Bible and two different gods right no
what I'm saying that the god of the
Bible I believe that the scribes have
light the look you have to listen to me
you have to listen look listen I believe
the god of the Quran and the god of the
Bible are the same however describes of
the Old Testament light against God
attribut the light to him for example
God rested and refreshed in a seventh
day that is not God's nature in the
Quran Allah refuted and debanked and
rebuked this light against him that God
rested and refreshed you understand God
does not rest human nature say God say
God don't rest that's human nature to
rest God is doesn't get tired god is
perfect in everything perfect in power
perfect in knowledge perfect in Mercy
perfect cannot come over him he cannot
be hit by fatigue in any way like he
doesn't go to the toilet
yes do you understand these are
deficiencies how can we experience
fatigue if God doesn't because he made
you deficient so you can turn back to
him but the problem is you are cing how
can we experience fatigue if God doesn't
he doesn't need to feel it he knows
about it cuz he created it yeah that he
created these feelings right yeah but
doesn't mean he's subject to it yes he
knows what must know what that feeling
feels like though no wait he knows what
it feels like but I'm saying to you but
he doesn't have it he must know right
wait wait Luke Luke Luke he's made the
feeling wait God create Luke Luke did
God create ignorance huh of course but
it doesn't mean he's ignorant cuz he
created it does he know what H feels
like he knows what it is cuz he created
it he made hunger right yes of course so
do you can he get hungry as well no no
because a deficiency self-sufficient
he's not in need of nothing everything
you see the God we worship is a perfect
God because he's self-sufficient if he's
self-sufficient Ro dictate he must not
feel any tired or hungry or any
deficiency you can't get hungry you
can't get tired that's what Allah the
Quran Allah
said the meaning of the verse Allah said
I have not created Jin and Mankind
except to worship me I'm not asking them
to feed me or to give me water because
Allah is a provider you know Allah
provides for everything you know provide
for Allah Allah provides everything you
see the God we worship is perfect in
everything by the god that you worship
he has deficiency in knowledge he has
deficiency in power he has deficiency in
everything that's why the scribes of the
Old Testament there were Liars they Li
against God they Li against the prophet
they Li against Moses they light against
Aaron they Li against Jeremiah they
light against Isaiah they against
Prophet Solomon you know and what your
SCH how many scholars are read this
Bible no no no what SCH how many people
wrote the Quran the Quran sah so how
many people wrote the the prophet
companions we have how many people
there's many of them wrot the Quran but
they saw Prophet mam directly but those
who wrote the Bible there were no
witness but it comes from one man yeah
from Allah no it comes from Muhammad
yeah no no from Allah it comes through
prophet Muhammad all the words it comes
from Muhammad Allah comes the of God the
words of God
con and then what Scholars wrote it down
compion comp companion down wrote it
down so you know you you know you know
you know watch this yeah not look they
came many years after yeah listen to you
carefully yeah no not for Jewish people
or the Israelites what about Cafe what's
Cafe not looking
ATA Cafe is a drink it's poish
milk no that's a Somali word
brother on Tik Tok too much you
know call me as
it means hardheaded person
like understand even he's a jar but
forget that forget that I'm not
J anyway look look listen care forget
don't worry about that you know if the
Israelites and the Christians and the
Muslims all of them decide to burn the
names for man bro you understand focus
focus look Focus if the Israelites and
the Muslims and the Christians burn the
scriptures the all scripture remain with
us is the Quran cuz we have memorized
word for word the letter for letter will
never be lost you know so what
about about I know this story ran into
the cave right he didn't run to the cave
he went to the cave he went into the
cave and then a spider made a web no
that's not true you don't believe that
no the story is not true that's that's
not in the Quran that's not in the Quran
it's not in the Quran not he went the
cas that's right when he was running
from his enemies his enemies yes went
the cave went into the
cave made that's not true that's not you
don't believe that it's not TR so what
happened his enemies went after him and
they were standing next to the cave and
His companion listen listen listen you
have to listen look hey look listen
carefully bro so he His companion said
to that's a miracle is it of course
that's a miracle is
it just so we clarify not that would
have been a miracle yeah it is a miracle
yeah Okay cool so they looked down and
they couldn't so they couldn't see them
cuz Allah blind them in the understand
Allah blind them about the spider what
what happened to the spider that's true
that's an important part of the story
but it's not true story we don't believe
in it l don't believe that yeah because
it's not true story where's that coming
from then bro come from fake from fake
stories fabric fabricating the ISL we
don't not accept anything because it
said about Prophet Muhammad no we have
to verify if it's true or not if it's
true accept it if it's fake we not
accept it but why we say you look look
you want toship what what mirac what
miracles do you got guys have in this
Quran the Mir the Quran is a miracle I
want to know the miracle the Quan is a
miracle so listen to this I know the
miracle yeah listen this give me the
miracle listen to this the Quran itself
is a miracle so one the miracle of the
Quran that Allah challenged the people
to bring something like it in his
eloquencer explanation List look so the
miracle of the Quran is the biggest
Miracle is the Quran CU Everlasting you
know so no the other when you say
Everlasting doesn't mean no means that
it's going to come a time when Allah
will raise everything the point here is
that the Quran Allah challenged the
people to bring something like it like
the Quran mean it
eloquencer in it structure
for focus focus meish
focus you're not interested let
him you know you're trying to counter
but you need to see what's coming out
you first 1,400 years ago and the
challeng is still on and no one is able
to the Quran also in the Quran Allah
speaks about that Islam will spread even
if disbelievers dislike it and we know
the fast growing Orion of the face of
the earth is Islam this a prophecy which
is another type of Miracle you know
likewise in the Quran Allah tell us the
uh about sping the moon where Prophet
Muhammad divide the moon split the moon
as a miracle you know so there's many
miracles all right I respect you guys
opinion on that yeah it's not opinion
well your beliefs I I respect I respect
your belief I grew up to respect
people's beliefs and that yeah but my
thing is this look you're saying that
black people
yeah talking about I think you're trying
to carry the conversation on from
somebody else have that conversation
with black people are nothing and no no
no you said that that that you say I'm
not blackit let me you look a black man
what do you black African man this wait
wait what do you think about a black
African man what do you think about
black African
man you believe Accord to his Bel as an
isite
afan's the Fest man plan know same Bo
same Bo yeah does what race does he
belong to what does that mean he's from
the Caribbean apparently does that mean
how come he's not a Somalian man bro
that's what I'm he's better than he's
better than just any other okay he's a
forest no problem
wa wait wait wait who's the best boxer
in the world who's the best who's the
best boxer in the world who's the best M
you tell us you tell us bro Muslim
Muslim Muhammad Ali Muslim mhammad Ali
Muslim Muslim Muslim he Muslim Muslim
Jama he African you
believe black America he's actually
origin apparently from Jamaica
apparently successful people to people
even greatest people on
the the greatest people on the planet
you understand we got all the great we
got Michael Jordan Floyd
maywe same all in the camp what about
the most intelligent you understand well
so just money basically that the money
no it's not money bro but I'm telling
the most
talenten look
is African man isite African ACC to is
not isite so may ACC to is not Israelite
what you praising him for no he's
a
afan anyway Hey listen black man is
good black is God my boy which black can
African watch subz news as well and
he'll tell you black
AF you slightly want it to go viral
black you understand
slly want to go viral I don't want to go
viral best believe and don't put this on
your YouTube no we have
to just subscribe you can watch it later
your YouTu that's us us D the best the
best channel in the world you're going
to do what the
whole
unedited is
that horrible I'm look you look all
right man you look all right you look
all right man look mad it you look right
man
come on man it's to
meet I don't I don't want to come up
here keep
trolling I'm not trolling slightly you
like it slightly you like it Wasing oh
man give me some stuff give me some but
you the most that's what I'm saying you
not the most racist people no you're
racist you believe black what do you
about the white man what do you about
the white man what you about the white
man all right listen what do I think the
white man
yeah white man hates black man man no is
he good or bad the white
man he's all right everyone's cool man I
mean everyone's cool man got on camera
and that but no most I can't bro my
opinions are so up you swear
don't swe my are so not politically
correct I can't just say them out
loud Islam is not about skin color about
your belief and your actions like I said
to you there's a good white people and
there's good black people
most white people are racist to black
people I don't believe that the most I
can't say the most you can't say that
you can't say that no no you can't say
that
man I exp over 20 years to be honest
there London they're very cool people
man they respectful you understand so we
should
not have to
go all right guys
pilgrimage at Mecca is an is an
anthropologist would be an
anthropologist Paradise because it's the
only event and the only spot on Earth
that has every specimen of humanity in
the same place at the same time uh
practicing Brotherhood and in harmony
it's the only place where I've ever seen
Brotherhood practiced by people of all
Races of all uh of everything has this
been a religious experience definitely I
went uh because of my religious beliefs
and I think that I have a better
understanding of my religion I I was a
state guest while I was there for 12
Days a prince uh faal who is the present
leader of the government he gave me he
made uh he made everything available to
me to give me every opportunity to get a
better understanding of the religion of
Islam uh when I first got there I was in
a compound because it wasn't known that
I was there and once they found out I
was there they put me in a in a suite at
the jeda palace Hotel gave me a a car
with a chauffeur and a mut who could
speak Arabic and take me wherever I
wanted I could go back and forth between
Mecca and jedha every night if it was my
desire I have never been given more
hospitality and treated with more
Brotherhood than I was treated in Arabia
by the by the Muslims there